moi je suis solaire solaire
je suis je suis bonne vivante donc
ça c'est un don parce que du coup quand
tout le monde fait un peu la tronche et
bah ça ça porte un peu les gens
c'est pas avec ça que tu vas faire une
carrière j'ai fait avec ça c'est pas
possible tu fais autre chose un autre
don un autre truc que tu fais mieux que
les autres si je suis honnête avec vous
je suis le meilleur amant du monde
[Applaudissements]
formé par une dame qui est venue
[Rires]
tu as été formé par a été formé par une
dame venue du ciel pour me transformer
en meilleur
[Rires]
je te jure vas-y je te jure que c'est
génial mais je suis pas je suis pas
chaud écoute je suis pas chaud tu vois
bah lui en fait c'est pour le visiter
pour savoir lui c'est comme un pays que
personne ne visiter mais je connais les
mecs qui dit ça pour que des meufs
fraîches
Daniel tu étais en train de la titiller
Daniel dit la vérité quand il dit ça tu
me diras Daniel Daniel a des titiée par
un donuts
[Rires]
frérot tu mets euh les petites des
petites sandales mais c'était tendu mais
de te coquillages là et euh avant de le
t-shirt ouais bah mets-le moi hein c'est
pas mal le faire et cette baisse ton
jean de
c'est un classique
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elle est tellement vieille qu'elle tient
toute seule
tu la mets elle tient toute seule
quoi
non mais sans déconner mais frère c'est
quoi ton don toi en particulier à part
ta façon de t'habiller
pourtant pour le style non mais c'est
vrai
j'en avais un mais évidemment je l'ai
perdu avec les âges et c'est quoi
j'étais une sauteuse hors pair
c'est-à-dire
incroyable
je sautais par exemple je sautais
j'avais une copine j'avais une copine
qui avait la même taille que moi elle
faisait juste ça et je sautais vous
savez comment on fait le soir
juste à baisser la tête et je sautais
j'avais une détente incroyable j'étais
toujours la dernière en ce ciseau
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'ai pas mon ticket
[Applaudissements]
alors ça c'était voilà merci la sauteuse
c'est quoi ton don toi moi j'ai un don
si vous me donnez la joie de vivre
[Musique]
les dates de naissance j'arrive à savoir
quel jour vous êtes né ah ouais
Daniel Moreau je peux dire
de naissance dans l'oreille donne-moi
les gens moi je peux la donner
de 9 ans 1963 de novembre
et comment tu sors je peux pas vérifier
tu vas à quelle date
tout de suite
vendredi et moi et moi tout le 29
février ah ça c'est un truc
je suis en direct à la téloche la petite
carte dis-moi je suis né quel jour moi
je dis
[Applaudissements]
elle est là
le jeudi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour madame
elle m'a raccroché au nez c'est horrible
non mais la famille c'est plus que
c'était donc là donc là
il te chie dessus aussi ah non mais je
te le dis moi je l'ai vu ah non non non
il y a Google on peut pas voir à Google
tu peux pas savoir mieux que ma mère
mais c'est quand est-ce qu'il est
difficile
d'abord je suis très l'axe
donc par exemple
et ça te sert pour te gratter
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je me suis [ __ ]
je te jure que j'ai mal là
avec tes doigts
arrête de me caresser comme ça
ça fait du bien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça peut être excitant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je l'ai jamais dit à personne mais je
sais rapper
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
normalement c'est un daronne qui te l'a
fait genre
[Rires]
tu viens de te raser pour la première
fois et que tu arrives à l'école le
lendemain tu as une station
d'avoir un petit duvet
de beau gosse moi j'avais un duo ici un
duvet ici
on m'a appelé deux balles slash
ok
je viens de la rue baisse les yeux sinon
je te bouffe le cul
[Applaudissements]
arrête c'est bien
alors la beauté n'est pas un don vous
soyez vous auriez tous un don ici c'est
un cadeau magnifique
si mon assistant peut prendre
rendez-vous chez l'ophtalmo
moi je pense que j'ai le don de
l'empathie l'empathie ouais c'est-à-dire
que quand je vois quelqu'un j'arrive à
ressentir ce qu'il pense enfin à mettre
disons dans un
télépathie
c'est-à-dire que j'arrive à ressentir ce
que la personne ressent bah tu sais ce
qui ressemble comment qu'est-ce qu'on
ressent un cocu
[Applaudissements]
en bas de tout le temps Raymond par
exemple
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il était en reconversion positive donc
est-ce que tu sens qu'il va bien en ce
moment là il est en
reconstructions
juste les deux stabilo dans le public
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
moi moi je vois des choses mais
des choses
[Rires]
je suis positif
[Applaudissements]
S
sur quelqu'un ici
sur les personnes ici
par exemple
je le voyais chercher Fatou
il a trouvé ou pas bah il a trouvé avec
en fait un
compagnon de route quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec un compagnon de route et il se rend
compte qu'en fait c'est pas vraiment
accompagné de route c'est le futur ou le
passé bah j'ai juste un flash non mais
en fait c'est le futur ça ça c'est le
futur c'était le passé c'est le futur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous aviez gagné aux machines à sous je
rigole pas et et il avait gagné aux
machines à sous et là en fait il y a un
gars qui arrive et qui lui dit non c'est
pas vous c'est l'autre
c'est possible
et ça c'est arrivé dans un casino
j'étais sur une machine pendant des
heures et des heures et des heures j'ai
lâché la machine le mec qui arrive juste
après moi
je lui ai sorti sa vie au bout d'un mois
je lui dis ça me rendrait dans la tête
je lui dis maintenant sur Google non non
je lui ai dit je lui ai dit écoutez vous
savez très bien que votre mari vous
trompe c'est que
pas devant tout le monde avec la meuf de
Casta
[Applaudissements]
je suis d'origine maghrébine
genre les gars c'est comme ça
j'ai mangé
un couscous et sache qu'après demain je
mange un tajine
de poulet au ciel on est à quelques mois
de l'Aïd el-Kébir
salut Cyril je me suis acheté des
chaussures hier enfin de Babouche
elle était tranquillement au jus là-bas
[Rires]
c'est comme si durant tout le dîner elle
m'a envoyé ce message dans ma tête qui
me faisait chier d'ailleurs et elle
était malheureuse il était à son mari
non et en partage j'étais au courant de
rien moi elle est venue avec anémone
l'actrice à l'époque sur pas la
flattrice pas la fleur
[Applaudissements]
et à la fin du repas je dis je peux vous
parler elle était triste la dame et je
suis allé lui avoir j'ai dit bon écoutez
je vais te cache avec vous je suis
désolé et tout ce que m'avez envoyé dans
la tête je vais vous dire ce que je vois
si vous le permettez je vous dis tout
allez-y votre mari vous trompe
occupez-vous de votre fille je ne savais
rien non si elle était mariée ça avait
une fiche ça avait rien et Anne du coup
anémone du coup c'est dingue tout ce que
tu lui as dit c'est incroyable c'est
vrai tout est vrai alors du coup elle
m'a appelé tout le temps et je lui ai
dit tu vas rencontrer un premier mec ça
va pas aller le deuxième non plus vous
allez croire ena et puis alors vous
rêvez d'aller aux Etats-Unis non c'est
ça elle me dit oui cela dit plein de
gens doivent aller aux États-Unis et je
dis vous irez pas aux États-Unis au
dernier moment où j'irai à l'île Maurice
ouais et ben c'est arrivé et c'est
arrivé 10 ans après c'est fou ça avec un
flash sur quelqu'un ici
on est passé
[Rires]
qui faisait le couscous ah oui
[Applaudissements]
on a mis du fauteuil toute la soirée
ça parle ça non
merci
quelqu'un d'ici euh non parce que j'ai
la vérité
attends regarde regarde
un flash
s sur personne ici je peux y
passerait hein
alors lui c'est noir oui c'est elle
c'est quoi c'est belge parce que
je connais les couleurs actuellement ça
veut dire ça que c'est sur le moment
présent
toi ça va mais en plus
de
nouvelles c'est à dire que tu as plein
de merde c'est mauvaise animaux
Delphine
c'est compliqué ah ouais elle est en
chemin c'est un chemin
elle est en cheminée
[Applaudissements]
je vois beaucoup de monde autour de
Fatou
qu'est-ce qu'elle a dans la bouche c'est
pas un micro
[Applaudissements]
-ondes
on ne dit pas la vérité
excuse-moi tu vois des choses
tu veux des Français
il est marrant le routier parce qu'il
est non tu as pas demandé ce que tu
pensais
de classe
[Rires]
je suis arabe
dans 2 minutes dans 2 minutes
la semaine prochaine
train de parler
[Applaudissements]
chez lui il est avec d'autres potes non
j'étais chez le berbère
on va pas déjà au niveau vestimentaire
c'est dramatique
outrancier
personnage non il y a ça pour plein de
choses
qu'est-ce que tu vois autour de la
lumière le halo autour de lui
non il est quoi
il est rouge il est bleu il est quoi il
est quelle couleur autour c'est positif
les bleus comme quoi bleu comme l'enfer
oh
parce que l'enfer c'est bleu
par contre la connerie elle est bien
rouge
[Rires]
est allé faire des investigations
j'investis rien moi c'est mes dons
je sens et j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
ta maman
je sens lui il est né vendredi je le
sais
tu t'attaques à la maman